hi I'm Ferran and hi I'm Troy what's up
I'm Jeff hi I'm destiny today we're
doing fer Faust black history edition
[Music]
I'm not very confident all I'm getting
these right I don't wanna lose my black
card in front of too many people I know
I'm nervous
history was my worst subject in school
it was history I'm hopeful that I'm
gonna do well I liked history in school
I just been out of school for so long i
watch a lot of jeopardy so I know a lot
of bizarre random fun facts not that
they really cover a lot of like text but
like maybe the idea of black history is
so vast I'm straight out of Indiana and
our history we weren't learning too much
about black people so what's a Trekkie
lucky I never one of the King was a big
Star Trek fan we did start I want to say
60s just just because the like I'm Sam's
boss I know that's I'm saying it was
around that era yeah you think it was
secret Trekkie I'm gonna say I'm gonna
say false just cuz I'm gonna go true cuz
I want it to be just what the difference
yeah
I'm saying false because I don't think
Star Trek was big enough for him to be a
big star yeah but my grandma used to
really like Star Trek I'm gonna say true
oh wow good-looking dude yeah I don't
know
I love Barack Obama like he feels like
family
such a G though this is like a body
model like swimsuit calendar model I'm
gonna say false because I think we
probably would have heard about
something yeah I'm sure like in today's
age something would have pop yeah I'm
gonna go false I'm going with true
because it could be like maternity
calendar model it could be like it sure
it could be like the Student Union
calendar like just thinking of like
ripped oily men and he just never gave
you did make a good point about like
that's disrespectful
they were like you ain't it well that's
fine but he's it never is Michelle was
like your idea hey she is the one that
voted for you oh I'm gonna I'm gonna say
false cuz I hope oh yeah I don't want it
to be true yeah at this point I'm going
with whatever you say no oh thank God
you said like Sheriff David Clarke
[Laughter]
[Music]
is that oh that's a question um I'm
gonna say true because I feel like a lot
of those techniques are not very great
for you here we felt like like hey all
the heat and stuff yes two falses in a
row wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait wait wait why are you saying
you know I think it motivated her more
yeah she was like mi you know what I
need a crazy history lesson please okay
I got uses yeah for some reason I just
feel like yeah anyway it's fitting you
know yeah I can see that I'm going false
cuz I I'm trying to think of anybody
that would have fit she's got
description Thanks
the streets just but I'm gonna go come
and go false I know but I'm saying I
think that's where they got the
inspiration from they're not gonna make
it I understand that I'm saying white
people got the inspiration for black
people I think that's what I'm saying
tell me I didn't have any of you ever
met a young Esther I haven't no they
just never born and then old that's it
my grandmother that was the last Esther
I knew I'd say that's 100 cent fact we
both know that yeah I don't think she
was the first I think she's maybe the
first document the first I'd like caught
on I don't know I know there was
somebody I just don't know who I'd like
so much black history I know I mean yeah
you know weird-looking face so I'm go to
go true I'm still gonna go true because
now it just looks like a phone doesn't
even know it was fallen destiny I don't
know what true so you know she followed
me this time boom she followed me okay I
need that something going on I'm gonna
Letta
I just saw this skill a lot of this with
him and Wilt Chamberlain nails it
doesn't matter let's go
[Music]
that's a lot of facts oh yeah i'ma say
yeah i'ma say false I'm actually gonna
say it was a different year later yeah
[Music]
I'm not gonna lie to you you said a lot
of facts and I was gonna say sure I
asked you to like to say the course
number or just like no oh really
then you choose Oh Baba she's like oh
check my numbers do okay yeah yeah yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
false he had a stutter
Oh false he had a stutter why not I
don't know what that rule was that like
a like a conspiracy yeah somebody was
saying that barbershop so I don't know
no way
oh yeah I say hope he was we're going
that sounds like something maybe fault
he dropped a lot of women saying this I
feel like she's from San Francisco so
it's gotta be false
[Music]
I Drive streetcar let's say I feel like
I heard that but then I'm gonna be wrong
I'm gonna get roasted someone's gonna
say yes because I better be blue
I think it's Warner it might be a
specific shade red red color nationally
recognized by the color wheel if I could
buy a state
I'm buying a state to say I wanna say
anything
[Music]
I learned that Maya Angelou was a
streetcar conductor
yeah yeah I play my history teachers I
play everybody in the city and you know
what I don't blame myself I on the other
hand did a lot better than I thought I
would do my favorite fact was probably
MLK being a tricky because that's
amazing you never hear about that my
favorite fact out of these was the one
about Claudette Colvin because it kind
of highlighted that she was there before
Rosa Parks and like no one talks about
that that's true my favorite fact was
one about jay-z in the blue because
again like I said if I had that kind of
money I would do the same thing like to
buy my own shade of pink call it def see
people Jeffrey Wright green true lending
I might get a raise
I need to open up a black book just in I
knew about coming of stories and about
some of those just the tales and stuff
but I didn't know the names and I think
that's working on them what I want to
learn I think I need to learn more about
like what really happened I feel like a
lot of history that we learned in school
black histories whatever it was a little
more storybook version even though all
of it wasn't happy it just was there's a
lot of details left out
you
you